PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH, HE WAS BASICALLY MAKING
THE ARGUMENT ABOUT THE SAKE OF
DEMOCRACY WHEN IT COMES TO MATH.
AND HE WAS ASKED TODAY AS HE WAS
TRYING TO DRAW THAT DISTINCTION
LAST NIGHT, SAYING ALL
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT MAGGIE
MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
TODAY, HE WAS ASKED IF HE
CONSIDERED ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS
TO BE A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS HOW HE ANSWERED.
>> I DON'T CONSIDER ANY TRUMP
SUPPORTER TO BE A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY.
I DO THINK ANYONE WHO CALLS FOR
THE USE OF VIOLENCE, FAILS TO
CONDEMN VIOLENCE WHEN IT'S USED.
FAILS TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN AN
ELECTION IS WON, INSISTS UPON
CHANGING THE WAY IN WHICH THE
RULES YOU COUNT VOTES, THAT IS A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> CHRIS, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> IT SEEMS TO ME A LITTLE BIT
OF A DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE THERE.
I THINK WHAT HE DOESN'T WANT TO
SAY, BECAUSE HE'S JOE BIDEN AT
HEART, THIS IS A GUY WHO DID RUN
AS SORT OF THE UNIFIER, THE GUY
WHO WAS GOING TO BRING THE
COUNTRY BACK TOGETHER.
I THINK HE DOESN'T WANT TO SAY
ANY AMERICAN IS A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY.
AT THE SAME TIME, LOTS AND LOTS
OF PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS TRUMP
SUPPORTERS HAVE SAID AND HAVE
RUN ON THE IDEA THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS NOT FAIRLY
CONDUCTED.
SO HE'S SAYING THEY'RE A THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY IF THEY BELIEVE
THAT, BUT THEY'RE NOT A THREAT
TO THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S A HARD DISTINCTION TO
DRAW.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THE SPEECH
LAST NIGHT, KAITLAN, WAS 68 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THAT'S A POLITICAL SPEECH.
I THINK IT WAS DONE ON PURPOSE
BY JOE BIDEN AND HIS AIDES TO
SET A STANDARD BY WHICH HE WAS
GOING TO CAMPAIGN ON.
I THINK THE QUESTION HE GOT
TODAY A LITTLE BIT MORE OFF THE
CUFF PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO THE SORT OF WHO JOE
BIDEN INHERENTLY IS, WHICH IS HE
DOESN'T WANT TO VILIFY, BUT THE
NATURE OF CAMPAIGNS IS TO DRAW
THOSE DISTINCTIONS, AND MY GUESS
IS YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR MORE OF
THE RHETORIC WE HEARD LAST NIGHT
FROM BOTH BIDEN AS WELL AS
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES BETWEEN
NOW AND NOVEMBER 8th.
>> YEAH, DO YOU THINK THIS IS
PART OF THIS LARGER EFFORT BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO BASICALLY
FRAME A VOTE IN NOVEMBER FOR
REPUBLICANS, FOR CERTAINLY THE
ONES WHO STYLE THEMSELVES AFTER
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS A
VOTE FOR EXTREMISM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BEEN
CLEAR THAT HE'S RAISING THE
STAKES OF THIS ELECTION.
THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT
DISAGREEMENTS OVER TAX OR
CLIMATE OR HEALTH POLICY.
HE SAID THIS IN THE SPEECH LAST
NIGHT, IT'S ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY, ABOUT WHETHER
AMERICANS WANT TO CONTINUE
FORWARD WITH A DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM
OF GOVERNING OR WHETHER THE
COUNTRY IS GOING TO MOVE
BACKWARDS.
I THINK HE'S BEEN VERY CLEAR IN
WHAT HE VIEWS AS THE STAKES OF
NOVEMBER'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS,
AND I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT, AND HE NOTED THIS IN
THE SPEECH, THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES WHO
HAVE WON PRIMARIES THIS YEAR WHO
HAVE SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE
WILLING TO CHANGE ELECTION LAWS
AND STILL DON'T ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE 2020 ELECTION,
INCLUDING THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR PENNSYLVANIA
GOVERNOR, DOUG MASTRIANO, WHICH
IS WHERE BIDEN WAS DELIVERING
THE SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
>> YOU COULDN'T IGNORE WHERE HE
WAS, CHRIS.
HE'S IN PENNSYLVANIA.
HE HAS BEEN THERE SEVERAL TIMES
ALREADY.
HE'S GOING BACK THERE ON MONDAY.
BUT ALSO TOMORROW, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
PENNSYLVANIA TO CAMPAIGN AS
WELL.
HE'S GOT SEVERAL CANDIDATES
THERE THAT HE'S ENDORSED.
SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE IDEA
THAT BIDEN WAS ARGUING LAST
NIGHT THAT THIS ISN'T REALLY A
REFERENDUM ON HIS PRESIDENCY
COME NOVEMBER.
THEY HAVE STRUGGLED WITH LOW
APPROVAL NUMBERS, HIGH INFLATION
THAT WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT,
BUT HE SEEMED TO BE FRAMING IT
AS THIS IDEA OF NORMAL VERSUS
NOT NORMAL.
>> LOOK, THERE'S NO QUESTION,
KAITLAN, THAT THE IMPROVEMENT IN
DEMOCRATIC PROSPECTS, AND I
DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
FAVORED TO KEEP THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
I STILL WOULD SAY REPUBLICANS
ARE PROBABLY SLIGHTLY FAVORED IN
BOTH.
BUT THE IMPROVEMENT IN
DEMOCRATIC PROSPECTS HAS COME
WITH JOE BIDEN'S RECESSION A
LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF NOT BEING
IN THE NEWS FOR ALL THESE
NEGATIVE STORIES ABOUT GAS
PRICES AND INFLATION, AND WHO
COMING INTO THE FORE MORE AND
MORE, DONALD TRUMP.
THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH.
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT IT, WHAT HAS
COME OUT ABOUT IT.
SO THE MORE THAT IT'S A CHOICE
BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND WHAT JOE
BIDEN REPRESENTS TO THE AVERAGE
SWING VOTER AND DONALD TRUMP AND
WHAT DONALD TRUMP REPRESENTS TO
THE AVERAGE SWING VOTER, THE
BETTER IN BIDEN'S MIND FOR
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IF YOU GAVE A REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST TRUTH SERUM, THEY
WOULD BE PERFECTLY HAPPY IF
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T SAY -- I WAS
GOING TO SAY TWEET, BUT I DON'T
KNOW, TRUTH SOCIAL, SOMETHING
BETWEEN NOW AND THE ELECTION.
THEY WOULD BE PERFECTLY HAPPY IF
DONALD TRUMP CAMPAIGNED FOR
CANDIDATES, THAT'S FINE, BUT IF
HE SORT OF STAYED AS LOW PROFILE
AS DONALD TRUMP COULD STAY.
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE FOCUS
STILL TO BE ON JOE BIDEN.
THERE IS STILL QUESTIONS ABOUT
JOE BIDEN'S HANDLING OF THE
ECONOMY.
YES, THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE GOTTEN
A LITTLE BETTER FOR JOE BIDEN OF
LATE, BUT THERE ARE STILL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
HIS HANDLING OF FOREIGN POLICY.
THERE'S PLENTY OF QUESTIONS AND
HISTORICAL ARGUMENTS THAT
SUGGEST THIS SHOULDN'T BE A GOOD
ELECTION FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE COUNTER IS WE HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO IS MORE HIGH
PROFILE IN WAYS WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE AND CONTINUES TO BE
SO.
AND THAT'S THE THING THAT
REPUBLICAN STRATEGISTS I TALK
TO, THAT'S WHAT WORRIES THEM.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A PERSON LIKE
DONALD TRUMP LOOMING OUT IN A
MIDTERM ELECTION LIKE DONALD
TRUMP IS LOOMING.
THAT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN'S SORT OF
LATCHING ONTO.
>> I GUESS THAT'S THE NATURAL
NEXT QUESTION.
TRUMP IS IN PENNSYLVANIA
TOMORROW.
HE'S ENDORSED A LOT OF THESE
CANDIDATES THAT HE BOOSTED THEM
IN THE PRIMARY, BUT NOW IT'S
STRUGGLING TO TRANSLATE THAT
MOMENTUM INTO GENERAL ELECTION
VOTES.
CERTAINLY, JUDGING BY THE POLL
NUMBERS RIGHT NOW, FOR PEOPLE
LIKE DR. OZ, IN PENNSYLVANIA,
WHO HAD KIND OF WRAPPED HIMSELF
IN TRUMP DURING THE PRIMARY, BUT
NOW THAT HE HAS SECURED THE
NOMINATION AND HE'S GOING AHEAD
IN THIS GENERAL ELECTION, HE'S
NOT AS CLOSELY HUGGING TRUMP AS
HE WAS PREVIOUSLY.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT, AND I
THINK CHRIS MADE A GREAT POINT,
WHICH IS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
STUCK IN THIS POSITION NOW WHERE
THEY HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE OF HIS
GROWING LEGAL PROBLEMS AND THE
INVESTIGATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO PUT -- MANY
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO PUT
DISTANCE BETWEEN THEMSELVES AND
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING
TROUBLE DEFENDING HIS POSSESSION
OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WHICH OF
COURSE HAS LOOKED INCREASINGLY
SERIOUS OVER TIME.
THEY'RE GETTING DISTRACTED
TALKING ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT THE CURRENT PRESIDENT AND
HIS RECORD.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THESE
CANDIDATES RECOGNIZE THAT, AND
YOU HAVE SEEN THEM BACKING OFF
SOME OF THE MORE EXTREMIST
POSITIONS THEY MAY HAVE ADOPTED
WHEN THEY WERE TRYING TO WIN
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT IN THE
PRIMARIES.
YOU SEEN A NUMBER SOFTEN OR TAKE
AWAY LANGUAGE ABOUT DENYING
ELECTION RESULTS OR RIGGED
ELECTIONS ON THEIR CAMPAIGN
SITES.
OBVIOUSLY, THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION, OVERTURNIN